dance with the devil don't become the
devil whereas I say it dance with the
devil don't become the devil
[Music]
so I'm out here today waiting for the
big homie Pauly Shore okay the weasel
bro
Pauly Shore dear friend iconic actor I
kind of comedian you known from movies
such as Encino man in the army now
son-in-law he was also one of the first
guys who took me on the road and kind of
taught me the ropes and what better way
to pay homage to such a comedy legend
than to take him to one of the most
historic iconic best taco spots in
America Taco Bell
then he's gonna love this dude where are
we
Taco Bell bro but what do you mean bro
dude where you taking me to this crusty
restaurant bro yeah bro with the Jews I
think everyone has a Polish or
impression except Pauly Shore he's just
like dude what are you talking about I
don't sound like that who knows he's not
gonna see this one coming
or maybe he will cuz he got the call
sheet and it says Taco Bell and then the
address but maybe he didn't read it
Pauly over here no it's perfect
you wretched laundry what's up bro
sorry okay no you're good bro thanks for
coming out man I'm excited I don't know
what we're doing dude where do I change
oh no you're good to go no no I got
special clothes more more special than
that this is great where do I go to
change you can do it here I mean where
where is the [ __ ] food what are you
doing to me wrong there's [ __ ] food
here now you're sitting on the yo dudes
so a legendary spot for a legend we're
gonna order some Taco Bell bro dude is
this [ __ ] am I being Punk'd on this
[ __ ] show what are you doing to me
dude why are you giving Taco Bell
I can't we go in a nice place this is
nice
do or anything I don't know what the
[ __ ] I don't know what the [ __ ] we're
doing oh you didn't prep me with [ __ ]
okay can I get two Doritos Locos Tacos
that's not [ __ ] Taco Bell dude Taco
Bell's burrito Supremes and chalupas
okay you want a burrito supreme
no no chalupa can we get two chalupas
and then I can I get two cinnamon twists
that's not here to crunchy tacos that's
not here and a quesadilla yeah look
you're an iconic comedian that's built
into like pop culture and Americana and
I think Taco Bell reflects that you're
very much Taco Bell you love talk of
course no ketchup dude just mayonnaise
sauce hot sauce yeah
muchas gracias king of India
[Applause]
[Music]
dude I'm hungry you hungry bro
you hungry you're hungry ah you gotta be
quick bro where would you rank the
original taco like if you had to compare
it to like a comedian what would you say
is like the original taco yeah maybe
like Freddie Prinze I think you're doing
it for a different kind of correlations
I thought was that racist hey do you raw
get in trouble gambrel a lot of a Taco
Bell joke Oh what is it
Taco Bell is like that chick you run
into at the end of the night at a club
yeah you know it's not good for you be
like right Taco Bell is one of those
things were just like everyone has a
joke it's like the butt of the joke you
know do you feel like in comedy or
sometimes a bit of a joke all right I'm
gonna leave now
hey bro give me a ride I think I used to
mostly be a butt of a joke breath I
think Hollywood's like a Mexican gang
initiation okay you know what I mean
Bobo why do you think that because I was
so whatever it is that I did was pop
culture so when you get in pop culture
you're in people's psyche so I was like
I was everywhere and when someone is
everywhere it's too much
yeah I mean you've been at it for so
long and that's one of the things that
really took like I take it serious let
that take it serious Yeah right
except for if you're showing up to a
sis's show on the street then whatever
you can get here you know we're just
happy to have you whenever you get here
is fine but I grew up around all these
knuckleheads and I learned from them
because we're all like how did you not
get into drugs right like how do you
still [ __ ] like have your money and
you work and you're gonna cuz I learned
what not to
do dance with the devil don't become the
devil whereas I say it dance with the
devil don't become the devil sorry you
know when you first came on the scene in
your parking cars that's the first time
I ever saw you yeah and I come over here
to comb over in the silly glasses I'm
like that's a good look so when I saw
you I'm like oh this guy's funny and
then from there I'm like I brought you
on the road and you're pretty bad you
know bombing a lot yeah and then you
know you just got better and that's all
it is it's like that's you just you keep
doing it you know you keep doing it and
you had the thing already
but you had to like go out to American
feel that cadence a mexican-american kid
from Long Beach being able to go in
front of you know white America Aberdeen
you know across Wyoming or you know
Alabama like I remember that do you
remember that one it's like I opened for
you at a seafood restaurant and I came
off and there was two guys in the
audience and ghillie suits right and I
made this joke I said I love I love that
we're in Mobile Alabama I love that you
named this town after the architecture
in this town and the guy in the ghillie
suit was like boo you know we're kind of
doing that so after we were doing the
merge and you had left I was packing up
but those guys came up to me like can we
tell you a joke that can't be good
because like have you ever heard of the
Mexican pregnancy test that's when you
grab a burrito stick it in a woman if it
comes out with a bite in it you have
yourself a [ __ ] and they fell out like
bowling pins laughing I'm like sweating
like where's Pauly man I want to get the
hell right here but it's like I got
exposed to these audiences and be able
to adapt you know comedy wise and how do
I make a crowd in Alabama laughs Wyoming
just like I do here my hometown LA
so cool man we had Taco Bell I'm gonna
take you to a spot called Tito's tacos
which is basically Taco Bell but at the
mom-and-pop stage sounds good to me
let's do it rock let's go
[Music]
all right whoa get your tackle who you
trippingly bro you certainly this is a
to go stock alerting me very aggressive
whoa whoa
Tito's tacos this is it all right so how
are you that goes the community for beef
and cheese tacos so imagine you know
Tito's in a vodka no no that's wrong
Tito give her this of real vodka
Schettino so you go to the clubs now
that goes like I want [ __ ]
Tito's key lime yeah that's it but this
is a hot one
Oh stupid faith it's just chance my
friend yeah well I can listen Lisa
kazoos they look like a muchas muchas
gracias
he's from El be seen as they really
speak Spanish all right let's do it
let's do it thank you have a good night
[Music]
my wife's grandfather actually founded
Tito's tacos right here on Washington
place established 1959 they start with
tortillas made in downtown LA and
they're brought over here and fried Anna
taco Tito's is a stone ground corn
tortilla with shredded beef along with
shredded lettuce and some cheddar cheese
and today's recipes are the exact same
ones that we had 60 years ago all right
so look at that's massive it is massive
they got the lettuce they got the meat
on bottom I'm gonna got the sauces to
look they got red and you know they have
to have the what the green look at that
what's a good thing the red Nasreen the
color so the me it seems like it's like
what's it called when they soak it for a
while other Walla you know a lot oh yeah
I could have said anything right thing
you would have been like yeah that well
the beef here is not normal it's not
like what why is it a normal bra what's
wrong with it well it's just you know
it's aged you know wow you know it's
already just put it on thing that's
stuck it in here this is my point I'm
having it 24 hours that's what that guy
said oh no no but that sounded good so
the main difference is like even if you
compared to like a taco bell the tostada
itself like the show is like thicker
it's more to your right yeah the other
ones like kind of fragile they kind of
[ __ ] you get in Tijuana look if you're
real like full-on to you right now in
Mexico I don't know what side of the
wonton you went to bro well they don't
have the post thought I want yeah this
is more like authentic what brothel is
that this is more authentic so I wanted
to ask you do you think that with like
the success of a comic there's a comedy
change and the reason I say that is like
remember when mmm found his success and
he had that that lining of the line
basically is like I can't rap about
Brooklyn being broke no more I can't rap
about coke no more
like comedy do you think success kind of
changes that when I became more no no
less relatable but then when I wasn't is
known no it was funnier it was almost
like I became more real you know what I
mean like you know cuz you're like the
underdog like for me my best caught me
is self-deprecating making fun of myself
so if you're if you're known like Kevin
Hart there's like a multi
multi-millionaire well it's hard to be
self-deprecating when you're hopping in
a jet after your show from me
I'm hopping you know [ __ ] Hertz
rent-a-car I think the thing that Jim
Carrey has not done is stay connected to
America because I think he needs to
connect with people outside of his is
his biodome he's like living in a
biodome like my move he's living like a
private multi multi-million dollar house
and that's part of the reason why
constantly tour I mean I make a living
off of it but I constantly connected to
to America and I think that's so
important as a comic you work so hard on
this on this thing and then later you're
known for it but sometimes it backfires
or you get tired of it you know you're
like I'm over it or are you over it you
know it's like when you get people
coming at you going oh please don't do
that please
why was i doing it wrong yeah okay you
guys sit right here right there you guys
that's a real friend the other way you
know Christ sure would have done that
[ __ ] to you leave what oh yeah [ __ ] oh
no no no he would have been like dude
you say that okay yeah you guys can come
by so yeah it's the old story you know
you worked really hard to come up with
your own thing and then you work really
hard to get away from your own thing but
then you also don't want to bite the
hand that feeds you right I like for me
I'm 51 right now Wow
so it's what the [ __ ] is Wow I thought
you were younger yeah we're the same age
yeah which camera do I want to know so I
don't know I feel like I said it earlier
I feel like I've been in
can gang and I've been beat up so much
but I've made it out the other side and
now I've respect for everyone I feel
that's just what I feel maybe I don't
right and I also feel that I'm like the
Billy Joel of comedy like for instance I
could tour off my hits forever right
it's ready to go so it's like it happens
and also doesn't happen right you're
doing it you know you're slowly [ __ ]
like a baby coming up a vagina you're
like you're just kind of you know I mean
but at the end of the day if you love
what you do what you do I remember used
to say this a lot when we're on the road
it's like you can't choose comedy comedy
chooses you mm-hmm that's real life
because you think you choose comedy
you're like I'm gonna try then you get
you out of bed and it's inside of us
it's like you can't not not be inside of
you I don't know man you know we're
lucky that we have something that we
love to do a lot of people don't you
know and I think that's a blessing ya
know Thank You Man go go go go
peace peace peace I have no idea what
we're filming what we're doing but I've
just flown with it so over here with my
friend Kate Souza Trejo he's a very
funny comedian you guys are following
them around see you care about him and
you feel like you know things are gonna
work out for him so when we're older we
can look back on and be like yo look at
remember we're doing the [ __ ] taco
thing on the corner of the [ __ ]
Street I don't know what's going on I
miss flowing with it so
hey what's going on everybody for first
we feast I'm Sean Evans and you're
watching hot ones it's the show with hot
questions and even hotter tacos tacos
bro hey Suz Trejo is in the building
tacos con todo a new show on first we
feast Tuesdays at 11 a.m. this is the
initiation a last dab taco oh yeah hey
Suz Trejo
welcome to the family mom thanks ma'am
this is gonna hurt tomorrow